back here in the states there is fear on
end around the campus of the University
of California Davis after three separate
stabbings in the last week two victims
have died and one is in critical
condition no suspects have been named
and police are not sure yet if the
crimes are related as Carter Evans
reports these these recent outbreaks of
attacks is unlike anything this
community has dealt with before
I did not expect my senior year for any
of this to be happening especially in
Davis after multiple killings near the
University of California Davis there's
still no suspect in custody three
stabbings over the last week all within
roughly a mile of campus in a small city
which hadn't seen a homicide since 2019.
the last few days have been
shocking and Incredibly challenging for
our community
it All Began last Thursday when the body
of 50 year old David bro was found with
multiple stab wounds in a local park
two days later UC Davis student Kareem
Abu najim was also stabbed to death in
another Park about a mile north of
Campus I just call on every every person
in a capacity to help to capture whoever
did this to please do so his father says
he was a free spirit his spirit is is
way of doing things
will will be with us until our last day
Monday night the violence continued
officers responded to a homeless
encampment near campus and found a woman
who'd been stabbed multiple times she's
now in critical condition in her attack
police say they're looking for a male
suspect between five six and five nine
with a light complexion curly hair and a
thin build everybody is asking are these
three crimes connected and it seems
certainly seems more probable than not
that they are for CBS mornings I'm
Carter Evans